[Musique]
tu as le rythme dans la peau
c'est l'ambiance n'hésitez pas à réagir
à cette émission notamment par sms 41 ce
qu'ils y serait la pire mascotte de
toute l'histoire selon certains l'euro
commence en fin de semaine prochaine et
ce personnage inspiré du freestyle et du
banat un genre de foot2rue croule déjà
sous les critiques c'est un truc pour
jeunes voilà dit on comprend pas ce à
quoi franchement c'est la mère d'un
serveur au niveau des analystes très
bonne analyse
l'adaptation est parfaite sur le terrain
aussi ça se passe super bien
déjà je connaissais pas mal de deux
joueurs j'ai fait la connaissance de des
autres joueurs aussi et et voilà tout se
passe bien pour moi et j'espère que ça
va continuer je suis pressé de pouvoir
commencer un match aller les bleus
[Rires]
cherchent championne je vous croise ans
cédric cédric je vous présente notre
championne qui a bouffé l'histoire amuse
beaucoup les avocats belges au milieu
d'un texte de loi portant sur le prix
des médicaments
une recette de cuisine s'est immiscé un
gratin d'aspergés campagne plus
précisément cette recette est un
copier-coller malheureux d'une page
marmitons l'erreur ne s'est pas glissée
dans le texte de loi officielle mais
elle était tout de même visible sur le
site officiel du législateur dans une
rubrique jusqu'à présent jugée sérieuse
par bon nombre d'avocats encore ma patte
7 en commun
et d'été ma crème chocolatée aux
sanglots au double la reine et son
humour cher s'invente pêcher sur la
tamise alors ça vous inspire quoi à
touba tamise
c'est le truc froid nous aussi on veut
way pour la tamise mais c'est quoi une
tamise la tamise je sais pas ce que
c'est le tamise c'est mais encore ces
signes ben ça rame c'est bien ce soir
souvenez de la phrase que vous dites que
c'est ça est-ce que vous pensez que le
candidat idéal au jir fait le casting
alors wendy est ce que vous pensez être
le candidat idéal
non je ne pense pas être le candidat
idéal je suis sûr d'être le candidat
idéal parce que ce qu'ils pensent et ce
qu'ils perdent entre ce qui est dit et
non pensée entre ce qui est pensé et non
dit beaucoup d'amour ce père l'envoie ya
trop de gens qui veulent me voir en
couple avec les filles de là où ça mais
c'est des douanes pour moi elles sont
trop bien ils ont 22 piges 23 24 ont
terminé c'est votre caractère exigeant
qui peut faire peur à la télévision non
j'étais un emmerdeur je le suis plus
donc voilà on vit aujourd'hui
voilà c'est vrai que les choses
aujourd'hui on veut qu'elle soit un peu
plus qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qui a
poussé des poubelles s'était contenté
mais qui mord yard il fait ses débuts
belle amazone qui a laissé disponibles à
la vente un tee shirt au flocage août un
t-shirt avec une étoile jaune et portant
la mention non vaccinés qui est qui a
très vite suscité un tollé sur les
réseaux sociaux
regardez il est vendu 17 dollars soit à
peu près 14 heureux pour ce t-shirt et
bien aucun nom de vendeurs n'étaient
précisé sur le site il était simplement
affiché comme vendus par amazon
'l'annonce a évidemment déclenché un
tollé des milliers de tweets appelant au
boycott de la plateforme qui a mis
quelques heures avant de retirer la non
ce sens pour l'instant s'expliquer
communiquer officiellement ou même
s'excuser tout simplement le mas est la
dernière chose c'est la dernière chose
qui reste c'est une habitude plutôt
saine il faut le dire dans les lieux
fermés les transports évidemment mais
même dans les vieux extérieur quand il
ya beaucoup de monde ce a permis de
faire
repousser un certain nombre d'épidémie
qu'on regardait la gastro entérite par
exemple n'a pas eu cette année oui c'est
la dernière chose qui reste je regardait
un reportage sur des naturistes ce
week-end il avait rien sauf un masque
donc c'est vraiment la dernière chose
qui reste quand on a tout en respectant
des perspectives changement de look qui
va surprendre et amuser nos deux patrons
c'est franchement ils ont fait du bon
c'est une dimension parler de jacques
chirac jacques chirac ancien président
doit de la cocaïne dont il est issu
mélina la louche c'est incroyable avec
dassault allez soyons scène
[Musique]
du sang froid dans l'est
il va de soi
j'aime beaucoup l'époque je suis
allemand je n'en doute pas et ensuite je
trouve très jolie voix là et maintenant
on a la copie mais un peu moi un peu
plus un peu moins un peu un peu plus
chiante quoi jean s'engageant dans ce
texte paraît-il oui regardez
merci c'est flagrant ah ouais je fais ça
vous dit me jean 14 ans du tout et je
suis le fils caché de jean castex voilà
je le dis je m'en fous il ya un an de
boîtes de préservatifs
je suis moi j'ai changé lui dit je vais
prendre du crès parce que castex ne le
sont pas taïg khris en niveau 6 pour te
venger de certaines personnes oui mais
ça chirac en particulier pourquoi
dimanche il m'avait donné 2 sec et a
pris la fuite position
alors un jour il me fait une commande
100 g comme d'habitude pour les chez
dassault donc je vais chez dassault mais
je prends 50 grammes et je m'élance avec
50 g de laxatifs l'homme manifestent
tous les symptômes d'une réaction
allergique très violente qu'on disait tu
lis je suis temps luca caf
oui comme c'est joliment dit liquide aux
veines sont
lee qui vous négocié liquide veine
parodique et du fiso craquer les auteurs
99 cents
applaudissements vraiment et vous savez
pourquoi
parce que c'est la 100e de votre c'est
quand j'ai présenté ma famille ma copine
julie je te préviens dans leur famille à
un besoin de monde à la gueule un pont
rouge en deux endroits où on a du public
au mois bakou franchement on commence la
semaine sur le jus avec level si je peux
me permettre